hello and welcome to Kerbal space
program this is an idea I had a little
while ago but I am basically to
apologize for my draw my life video
being late I thought I'd try this out
now this if you don't know is a game
which is all about controlling your own
space agency you have a certain amount
of money a certain amount of technology
which is available to you and you
undertake missions to expand both your
money and your technology and what I
thought it is that this would be a great
opportunity to teach a little bit about
rocket science about the history of
spaceflight which are both topics I'm
really really into what's playing the
game so I've got a campaign which I
haven't done anything on but I've
already started down here and I thought
that there we go haven't even clicked
off the first tooltip so I thought that
basically we could do a couple of
missions and see how this goes if we go
over to the astronaut center you see
that I am ooh so what I want to do this
playthrough is I want to have my
subscribers as my Kerbal moles so all
these people we can rename and we can
put them into our spacecraft so if you
would like to be an astronaut or really
a curb L'Amour then hit me up let me
know if you'd like to be part of this
and we can we can put you into space or
possibly you might die in a fiery
Inferno I can't guarantee that won't
happen
but let's find out so the way that this
now works jeanne yurman
so Jeanne Kerman is interesting I think
he's named half after Gene Cernan who
was the Poli 17 astronaut and also to
Gene Kranz who was the Apollo 13 mission
commander but like um
mission director but will more about
that later so what we have to do is we
can choose two contracts at a time so
this is a pretty easy one all we have to
do is literally launch a vessel so we
can accept that and let's see if we can
on our first attempt gets 5,000 meters
however these are going to give us
rewards down here we can use those
rewards of money reputation and science
to expand what we do but to build
something we need to go to this the
Vehicle Assembly Building Verner von
Karman is of course Wernher von Braun
who is the from the famous originally
Nazi then later American Life Sciences
so this is where a lot of fun actually
the game happens so what we have here is
our clan pot now this is the only
command pub we have available to us as
we develop more science we can have more
available to us and you can see it's you
know it's got various characteristics
and we have all these different parts
here so then you got a few of the moment
because we haven't got our huge amount
of science but all we need to do is we
need to get to 5,000 meters of me to
launch of US Senate's to watch a vessel
we need some fuel
allow to view swine on
it's literally giving those basic rocket
can have a liquid-fueled engine that's
it that's lit shell first crop oh but
that's not really enough because this
goes up then what happens we need to
safely get this back down
so let's first parachute ox now what
you'll need something here on the right
here this is our stages so rockets are
composed of multiple stages people if
you have a very simple rocket then it is
literally just one stage just like the
engine and that's it but what we want to
do is we want to launch this rocket and
then we want to get at the atmosphere
then we want to return it safely and we
do that is via this parachute so we make
that our second stage so that first
stage is this engine here we press space
bar that is the gearing game and that
fires the engine grateful fuel to run
out and then just fully hit the ground
we want to hit this parachute and that's
literally it
let's make sure that we take jebediah
Kerman out and we're gonna put me in I
really hope I don't die I kind of like I
said I can't guarantee that that won't
happen
and we can name our craft the other
thing is I want names for spacecraft so
I'm going to name it the brutal bump
trinket if you get that reference you
are awesome but as well as having
willing subscribers so get a volunteer
to be part of the space program I also
need your spaceship names so let's
launch it and hope it doesn't all blow
up okay so this is our launch pad
that's our Space Center over there so we
actually had to be very careful not to
damage our Space Center because we have
to spend some of our very hard earned
money fixing it if something does go
wrong so there's me I can actually go
inside the crew capsule here it's a bit
bare it can't really see much at the
moment and this thing you also see down
here so this is our trackable and this
is basically what indicates our our
orientation or attitude as is the space
temperate so we've got a throttle there
on the Left we've got our acceleration
on the right if it goes into the red
that that's pretty much toast for our
cobalt and we have our speed here so I'm
going to do oh I can't gauge SAS I
literally can do nothing okay
so this could be fun let's try launching
this without anybody who has any
piloting knowledge three two one go so
PC we've completed one contractor money
I'm a fly now you can see on the
left-hand side here we have our fuel
gauge can actually see we're using this
top tape first and then it eventually we
use that left angle but if you can see
the bottom we're actually shipping
around a little bit
interestingly I'm not sure why because
we are we don't have
and the asymmetry in our design and we
just hit 5,000 meters so we've hit both
of our objectives just good let's just
see how far it would encourage thinking
about it I probably had better let us
move a little bit inside
so we don't become crashing write that
down
on this playset so dig over a few and we
are if you look at this gauge at the top
here I'm taking this to be roughly the
stratosphere this is directed into three
layers in the Earth's atmosphere you
could really think of it as lower out so
middle atmosphere upper atmosphere space
and to me stratosphere is really the
middle atmosphere then above that you've
got the the thermosphere so amita sphere
than the thermosphere but we're probably
going to stop at a height just over 20
kilometers which is pretty good I think
pro first attempt now I can do actually
I can show you this is our map mode this
thing is huge because this is us that's
our tiny detector e of our planet and
we're actually going to come down and
see just a little bit annoying because
that means we'll lose some of our parts
visually we can reclaim parts afterwards
but you can see that's us we've just
gone over our Apple abscess which is the
highest point of an orbit when I came
back down to earth
well Kerbal kerbin sorry this is
basically the the system here in the
game is based on the earth system but
the earth is called kerbin and the moon
is mu n with animal out and also kerbin
has two moons rather than just one but
you also have all the other BOTS
planetary bodies so you have you have
Mars Venus Jupiter you have all of those
bodies just with different names and
they all have moons if they have means
in real world and we can go and visit
them this is a cycle actually speed up
tanks this is a little bit boring and
that's me looking a bit panicked and now
you're noticed we're slowing down
because that's the effect of atmospheric
drugs are in the lower part the answer
for now right just a couple of
kilometers when we hit two kilometers
I'll deploy a parachute so if i zoom out
you can see that better and there we go
so we're going to touch down the ocean
ocean touchdowns are um something the
Americans do that the the Soviet space
agency didn't move in the space race I'm
not entirely sure why because because
land touchdowns I suppose it easy to get
to because you have to send a recovery
vehicle out make sure everybody's
alright where's ocean touchdowns the
ocean is a bit more forgiving than
landing on you know hard ground look at
me I saw why if I fly I don't look too
happy about it and I can't see much
either that's probably why I'm not very
happy what we can do is there one of the
things about this game is in order to
unlock parts you need science so we can
get science by performing science
actions an example of that is doing crew
report so that's my report I like the
look at the sea so keep that data I will
recover that and we are about to touch
down they can fortunately we've lost the
parts below the crew capsule which is a
little bit annoying but if we would
cover the vessel there we go so we've
got this much science 13 in total we
recovered some of the parts and I got
some experience so pretty good now
that's science then if we go to our
research and development center which is
here we have a tech tree and these are
the parts that we have when we started
out with and I can do is I can use this
science which you've earned to unlock
these parts so these are more fuel
containers our best science and a stack
decoupler which is very important if we
want to try and make bigger rockets
because I'll explain about multistage
rockets in in the next part but they are
very important in order to get out the
atmosphere so for research that we now
have those parts and we can really have
a science left
so we don't actually have enough to
research these topics so what I want
from you guys then is I need quite a few
things in the comment section I need you
guys to volunteer yourselves in the name
of Kerbel science and volunteers Kerbal
mort's I need [ __ ] name's Nelson need
some directions so I need you guys to
recommend what we should do so whether
we should what technologies which gave
or what missions we should go for
there's not too much choice on the
technology from but in terms of missions
you actually have quite a lot to choose
from so we have these slightly more
ambitious ones at the moment considering
the parts we have like escaping out
searing orbiting kerbin but we can test
static as solid rocket boosters
parachutes visuals so these quote calls
this is literally just fly into a
location and doing and you get quite a
lot of money from doing that
but I want you guys to choose so this is
the only episode that I'm going to be
recording in this session normally what
I'll probably do is I records three
probably 10 to 15 minute episodes in a
sitting but because this is the first
one I need lots of Kerber more
volunteers and I need lots of direction
and I need lots of input from you guys
so I know what to do next so that's it
from me for the time being let me know
what you think about this concept as
well if you think it's a terrible idea
then do tell me in the comments but I if
you the music stops on I touched on
whether music stopped there we go we can
have a look at the tracking station what
so here we've got all of this to explore
we've got all the space photos email
actually that's kerbin then we've got
the moon we've got the second moon see
my even further all these other planets
as well and all their orbits so we've
got lots and lots to do and I need your
help to decide what we are going to do
so leave your feedback in the comments
bolon tear yourselves for science give
me some directions and hopefully I'll be
doing another episode in just a couple
of days time because this is really
really easy to do so hopefully we can
get this series off off the ground or a
terrible pun really quickly so thanks a
lot for watching guys and I look forward
to reading your suggestions in the
comments